all right it's time for drew's news your
daily news stir fry with that good news
sizzle and here with me is my trusty
co-pilot rossi ross max
i know i love you i love you
um we're starting with the beautiful
issue of people magazine everybody gets
so excited with that
and guess what oh look yes it's none
other than dame helen mirren um there's
also a really special story inside that
continues to celebrate women um it gives
a little inside look into the favorite
besties for all of us oprah and gail
they're finally telling
their origin story of the beautiful
friendship that we've all come to know
as that's my gale
um it all started 46 years ago on a
snowy night in baltimore oprah was 21.
gail was 22. and the two young newsies
we're following their dreams at wjtz
tv
and then this blizzard hit and oprah
invited gail over and they were like up
all night chatting they had this great
kind of evening that the weather brought
them together and the rest is history
you just never know when you're going to
meet your next bestie you know i've met
besties poolside i've been at a bar i've
met him at this very desk right here
you never know when you're going to need
a guy think about that who could you
meet next and they could be your next
best friend i love that idea all right
next we've got women bringing major
changes to the mlb in today's sports
sports sports
been too long since we've done sports i
know
well the wall street journal reports
this season there's a new record in
baseball listen to this 11 of the on
field coaches across the majors and
minors are women yep
it's pretty amazing
and you you know yeah yeah yeah
i'm thinking put this into perspective a
little bit since
2018 as recently as that there have been
zero there were zero female coaches
that's so crazy that's just
four years ago yes so think about where
we could be four years from now that's
what i like to think
so
let's shout out some of these coaches
this season alyssa nathan became the
very first woman ever to coach an mlb
game for that she looks so cool right
and the yankees just promoted rachel
balkovich to manager
she's the first woman to lead a team
in the minors and mlb we say keep it up
that's how you play ball yes that's
exactly right
[Music]